The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
As you're settling into your
seats, why don't we take 10
more seconds on the clicker
question here.
All right, so this is a question
that you saw on your
problem-set, so this is how many
electrons would we expect
to see in a single atom
in the 2 p state.
So, let's see what
you said here.
Six.
And the correct answer
is, in fact, six.
And most of you got
that, about 75% of
you got that right.
So, let's consider some people
got it wrong, however, and
let's see where that wrong
answer might have come from,
or actually, more importantly,
let's see how we can all get
to the correct answer.
So if we say that we have a 2
p orbital here, that means
that we can have how many
different complete orbitals
have a 2 for an n, and a p
as its l value? three.
So, we can have the 2 p x, 2
p y, and 2 p z orbitals.
Each of these orbitals can have
two electrons in them, so
we get two electrons here,
here, and here.
So, we end up with a total
of six electrons that are
possible that have that
2 p orbital value.
So this is a question that,
hopefully, if we see another
one like this we'll get a 100%
on, because you've already
seen this in your problem-set as
much as you're going to see
it, and you're seen it in
class as much as you're
going to see it.
So if you're still having
trouble with this, this is
something you want to bring
up in your recitation.
And the idea behind this, of
course, is that we know that
every electron has to have its
own distinct set of four
quantum numbers.
So that means that if we have
three orbitals, we can only
have six electrons in those
complete three orbitals.
All right, so today we're
going to fully have our
discussion focused on
multi-electron atoms. We
started talking about these on
Wednesday, and what we're
going to start with is
considering specifically the
wave functions for
multi-electron atoms. So, the
multi-electron atoms. Then
we'll move on to talking about
the binding energies, and
we'll specifically talk about
how that differs from the
binding energies we saw of
hydrogen atoms. We talked
about that quite in depth, but
there are some differences now
that we have more than one
electron in the atom.
Then something that you
probably have a lot of
experience with is talking about
electron configuration
and writing out the electron
configuration.
But we'll go over that,
particularly some exceptions,
when we're filling in electron
configurations, and how we
would go about doing that for
positive ions, which follow a
little bit of a different
procedure.
And if we have time today,
we'll start in on the
photo-electron spectroscopy,
if not, that's where we'll
start when we come back
on Wednesday.
So, what we saw just on
Wednesday, in particular, but
also as we have been discussing
the Schrodinger
equation for the hydrogen atom,
is that this equation
can be used to correctly predict
the atomic structure
of hydrogen, and also all of
the energy levels of the
different orbitals in hydrogen,
which matched up
with what we observed, for
example, when we looked at the
hydrogen atom emission
spectra.
And what we can do is we can
also use the Schrodinger
equation to make these accurate
predictions for any
other atom that we want
to talk about in
the periodic table.
The one problem that we run into
is as we go to more and
more atoms on the table, as
we add on electrons, the
Schrodinger equation is going
to get more complicated.
So here I've written for the
hydrogen atom that deceptively
simple form of the Schrodinger
equation, where we don't
actually write out the
Hamiltonian operator, but you
remember that's a series of
second derivatives, so we have
a differential equation that
were actually dealing with.
If you think about what happens
when we go from
hydrogen to helium, now instead
of one electron, so
three position variables,
we have to describe two
electrons, so now we have six
position variables that we
need to plug into our
Schrodinger equation.
So similarly, as we now move up
only one more atom in the
table, so to an atomic number of
three or lithium, now we're
going from six variables all
the way to nine variables.
So you can see that we're
starting to have a very
complicated equation, and
it turns out that it's
mathematically impossible
to even solve the exact
Schrodinger equation
as we move up to
higher numbers of electrons.
So, what we say here is we need
to take a step back here
and come up with an
approximation that's going to
allow us to think about using
the Schrodinger equation when
we're not just talking about
hydrogen or one electron, but
when we have these
multi-electron atoms.
The most straightforward way to
do this is to make what's
called a one electron orbital
approximation, and when you do
you get out what are called
Hartree orbitals, and what
this means is that instead of
considering the wave function
as a function, for example, for
helium as six different
variables, what we do is we
break it up and treat each
electron has a separate wave
function and say that our
assumption is that the total
wave function is equal to the
product of the two individual
wave functions.
So, for example, for helium, we
can break it up into wave
function for it the r, theta,
and phi value for electron
one, and multiply that by the
wave function for the r,
theta, and phi value for
electron number two.
So essentially what we're
saying is we have a wave
function for electron one,
and a wave function
for electron two.
We know how to write that in
terms of the state numbers, so
it would be 1, 0, 0, because
we're talking
about the ground state.
We're always talking about the
ground state unless we specify
that we're talking about
an excited state.
And we have the spin quantum
number as plus 1/2 for
electron one, and minus 1/2
for the electron two.
It's arbitrary which one I
assigned to which, but we know
that we have to have each of
those two magnetic spin
quantum numbers in order to have
the distinct four letter
description of an electron.
We know that it's not enough
just to describe the orbital
by three quantum numbers, we
need that fourth number to
fully describe an electron.
And when we describe this in
terms of talking about
chemistry terminology, we would
call the first one the 1
s, and 1 is in parentheses
because we're talking about
the first electron there, and
we would multiply it by the
wave function for the second
one, which is also 1 s, but
now we are talking about
that second electron.
We can do the exact same thing
when we talk about lithium,
but now instead of breaking it
up into two wave functions,
we're breaking it up into three
wave functions because
we have three electrons.
So, the first again is
the 1 s 1 electron.
We then have the 1 s 2 electron,
and what is our
third electron going to be?
Yeah.
So it's going to be the
2 s 1 electron.
So we can do this essentially
for any atom we want, we just
have more and more wave
functions that we're breaking
it up to as we get to more
and more electrons.
And we can also write this in an
even simpler form, which is
what's called electron
configuration, and this is
just a shorthand notation for
these electron wave functions.
So, for example, again we see
hydrogen is 1 s 1, helium we
say is 1 s 2, or 1 s squared, so
instead of writing out the
1 s 1 and the 1 s 2, we just
combine it as 1 s squared,
lithium is 1 s 2, 2 s 1.
So writing out electron
configurations I realize is
something that a lot of you had
experience with in high
school, you're probably --
many of you are very
comfortable doing it, especially
for the more
straightforward atoms. But
what's neat to kind of think
about is if you think about
what a question might have
been in high school, which is
please write the electron
configuration for lithium, now
we can also answer what sounds
like a much more impressive,
and a much more complicated
question, which would be write
the shorthand notation for the
one electron orbital
approximation to solve the
Schrodinger equation
for lithium.
So essentially, that is
the exact same thing.
The electronic configuration,
all it is is the shorthand
notation for that one electron
approximation for the
Schrodinger equation
for lithium.
So, if you're at hanging your
exam from high school on the
fridge and you want to make it
look more impressive, you
could just rewrite the
question as that, and
essentially you're answering
the same thing.
But now, hopefully, we
understand where that comes
from, why it is that we use
the shorthand notation.
So, let's write this one
electron orbital approximation
for berylium, that sounds like a
pretty complicated question,
but hopefully we know that it's
not at all, it's just 1 s
2, and then 2 s 2.
And we can go on and
on down the table.
So, for example, for boron, now
we're dealing with 1 s 2,
then 2 s 2, and now we have to
move into the p orbital so we
go to 2 p 1.
So that's a little bit of an
introduction into electron
configuration.
We'll get into some spots
where it gets a little
trickier, a little bit more
complicated later in class.
But that's an idea of what it
actually means to talk about
electron configuration.
So now that we can do this, we
can compare and think about,
we know how to consider wave
functions for individual
electrons in multi-electron
atoms using those Hartree
orbitals or the one electron
wave approximations.
So let's compare what some
of the similarities and
differences are between hydrogen
atom orbitals, which
we spent a lot of time studying,
and now these one
electron orbital approximations
for these
multi-electron atoms.
So, as an example, let's take
argon, I've written up the
electron configuration here,
and let's think about what
some of the similarities might
be between wave functions in
argon and wave functions
for hydrogen.
So the first is that the
orbitals are similar in shape.
So for example, if you know how
to draw an s orbital for a
hydrogen atom, then you already
know how to draw the
shape of an s orbital or
a p orbital for argon.
Similarly, if we were to look
at the radial probability
distributions, what we would
find is that there's an
identical nodal structure.
So, for example, if we look at
the 2 s orbital of argon, it's
going to have the same amount of
nodes and the same type of
nodes that the 2 s orbital
for hydrogen has.
So how many nodes does the 2 s
orbital for hydrogen have?
It has one node, right, because
if we're talking about
nodes it's just n minus 1 is
total nodes, so you would just
say 2 minus 1 equals 1 node
for the 2 s orbital.
And how many of those nodes
are angular nodes? zero.
L equals 0, so we have zero
angular nodes, that means that
they're all radial nodes.
So what we end up with is one
radial node for the 2 s
orbital of hydrogen, and we can
apply that for argon or
any other multi-electron atom
here, we also have one radial
node for the 2 s orbital
of argon.
But there's also some
differences that we need to
keep in mind, and that will be
the focus of a lot of the
lecture today.
One of the main difference is
is that when you're talking
about multi-electron orbitals,
they're actually smaller than
the corresponding orbital
for the hydrogen atom.
We can think about why
that would be.
Let's consider again an s
orbital for argon, so let's
say we're looking at the
1 s orbital for argon.
What is the pull from the
nucleus from argon
going to be equal to?
What is the charge
of the nucleus?
Does anyone know, it's a quick
addition problem here.
Yeah, so it's 18.
So z equals 18, so the nucleus
is going to be pulling at the
electron with a Coulombic
attraction that has a charge
of plus 18, if we're talking
about the 1 s electron or the
1 s orbital in argon.
It turns out, and we're going to
get the idea of shielding,
so it's not going to actually
feel that full plus 18, but
it'll feel a whole lot more
than it will just feel in
terms of a hydrogen atom
where we only have a
nuclear charge of one.
So because we're feeling a
stronger attractive force from
the nucleus, we're actually
pulling that electron in
closer, which means that the
probability squared of where
the electron is going to be is
actually a smaller radius.
So when we talk about the size
of multi-electron orbitals,
they're actually going to be
smaller because they're being
pulled in closer to the nucleus
because of that
stronger attraction because of
the higher charge of the
nucleus in a multi-electron
atom compared
to a hydrogen atom.
The other main difference that
we're really going to get to
today is that in multi-electron
atoms, orbital
energies depend not just on the
shell, which is what we
saw before, not just on the
value of n, but also on the
angular momentum
quantum number.
So they also depend on
the sub-shell or l.
And we'll really get to see a
picture of that, and I'll be
repeating that again and again
today, because this is
something I really want everyone
to get firmly into
their heads.
So, let's now take a look
at the energies.
We looked at the wave functions,
we know the other
part of solving the Schrodinger
equation is to
solve for the binding energy of
electrons to the nucleus,
so let's take a look at those.
And there again is another
difference between
multi-electron atom and the
hydrogen atoms. So when we
talk about orbitals in
multi-electron atoms, they're
actually lower in
energy than the
corresponding h atom orbitals.
And when we say lower in energy,
of course, what we
mean is more negative.
Right, because when we think
of an energy diagram, that
lowest spot there is going to
have the lowest value of the
binding energy or the most
negative value of binding.
So, let's take a look here at
an example of an energy
diagram for the hydrogen atom,
and we can also look at a
energy diagram for a
multi-electron atom, and this
is just a generic one here, so
I haven't actually listed
energy numbers, but I want
you to see the trend.
So for example, if you look at
the 1 s orbital here, you can
see that actually it is lower
in the case of the
multi-electron atom than it
is for the hydrogen atom.
You see the same thing
regardless of which orbital
you're looking at.
For example, for the 2 s, again
what you see is that the
multi-electron atom, its 2 s
orbital is lower in energy
than it is for the hydrogen.
The same thing we
see for the 2 p.
Again the 2 p orbitals for the
multi-electron atom, lower in
energy than for the
hydrogen atom.
But there's something you'll
note here also when I point
out the case of the 2 s versus
the 2 p, which is what I
mentioned that I would be saying
again and again, which
is when we look at the hydrogen
atom, the energy of
all of the n equals 2 orbitals
are exactly the same.
That's what we call degenerate
orbitals,
they're the same energy.
But when we get to the
multi-electron atoms, we see
that actually the p orbitals are
higher in energy than the
s orbitals.
So we'll see specifically why it
is that the s orbitals are
lower in energy.
We'll get to discussing that,
but what I want to point out
here again is the fact that
instead of just being
dependent on n, the energy
level is dependent
on both n and l.
And is no longer that sole
determining factor for energy,
energy also depends both
on n and on l.
And we can look at precisely why
that is by looking at the
equations for the energy levels
for a hydrogen atom
versus the multi-electron
atom.
So, for a hydrogen atom, and
actually for any one electron
atom at all, this is our energy
or our binding energy.
This is what came out of
solving the Schrodinger
equation, we've seen this
several times before that the
energy is equal to negative z
squared times the Rydberg
constant over n squared.
Remember the z squared, that's
just the atomic number or the
charge on the nucleus, and we
can figure that out for any
one electron atom at all.
And an important thing to note
is in terms of what that
physically means, so physically
the binding energy
is just the negative of
the ionization energy.
So if we can figure out the
binding energy, we can also
figure out how much energy we
have to put into our atom in
order to a eject or ionize
an electron.
We can also look at the energy
equation now for a
multi-electron atom.
And the big difference is
right here in this term.
So instead of being equal to
negative z squared, now we're
equal to negative z effective
squared times r
h all over n squared.
So when we say z effective, what
we're talking about is
instead of z, the charge on
the nucleus, we're talking
about the effective charge
on a nucleus.
So for an example, even if a
nucleus has a charge of 7, but
the electron we're interested in
only feels the charge as if
it were a 5, then what we
would say is that the z
effective for the nucleus
is 5 for that electron.
And we'll talk about this
more, so if this is not
completely intuitive, we'll
see why in a second.
So the main idea here is z
effective is not z, so don't
try to plug one in for the
other, they're absolutely
different quantities in any case
when we're not talking
about a 1 electron atom.
And the point that I also want
to make is the way that they
differ, z effective actually
differs from the total charge
in the nucleus due to an
idea called shielding.
So, shielding happens when you
have more than one electron in
an atom, and the reason that
it's happening is because
you're actually canceling out
some of that positive charge
from the nucleus or that
attractive force with a
repulsive force between
two electrons.
So if you have some charge in
the nucleus, but you also have
repulsion with another electron,
the net attractive
charge that a given electron
going to feel is actually less
than that total charge
in the nucleus.
And shielding is a little bit of
a misnomer because it's not
actually that's the electron's
blocking the charge from
another electron, it's more like
you're canceling out a
positive attractive force with
a negative repulsive force.
But shielding is a good way to
think about it, and actually,
that's what we'll use in this
class to sort of visualize
what's happening when we have
many electrons in an atom and
they're shielding each other.
Shielding is the term that's
used, it brings up a certain
image in our mind, and even
though that's not precisely
what's going on, it's a very
good way to visualize what
we're trying to think
about here.
So let's take two cases of
shielding if we're talking
about, for example, the helium,
a helium nucleus or a
helium atom.
So what is the charge
on a helium nucleus?
What is z?
Yup, so it's plus 2.
So the charge is actually just
equal to z, we can write plus
2, or you can write plus 2 e,
e just means the absolute
value of the charge
on an electron.
When we plug it into equations
we just use the number, the e
is assumed there.
So, let's think of what we
could have if we have two
electrons in a helium atom
that are shielded in two
extreme ways.
So, in the first extreme way,
let's consider that our first
electron is at some distance
very far away from the
nucleus, we'll call this
electron one, and our second
electron is, in fact, much, much
closer to the nucleus,
and let's think of the idea of
shielding in more of the
classical sense where we're
actually blocking some of that
positive charge.
So if we have total and complete
shielding where that
can actually negate a full
positive charge, because
remember our nucleus is plus
2, one of the electrons is
minus 1, so if it totally blocks
it, all we would have
left from the nucleus is an
effective charge of plus 1.
So in our first case, our first
extreme case, would be
that the z effective that is
felt by electron number 1, is
going to be plus 1.
So, what we can do is figure out
what we would expect the
binding energy of that electron
to be in the case of
this total shielding.
And remember again, the binding
energy physically is
the negative of the ionization
energy, and that's actually
how you can experimentally
check to see if this is
actually correct.
And that's going to be equal
to negative z effective
squared times r h
over n squared.
So, let's plug in these values
and see what we would expect
to see for the energy.
So it would be negative 1
squared times r h all over 1
squared, since our z effective
we're saying is 1, and n is
also equal to 1, because we're
in the ground state here so
we're talking about
a 1 s orbital.
So if we have a look at what
the answer would be, this
looks very familiar.
We would expect our binding
energy to be a negative 2 .
1 8 times 10 to the negative
18 joules.
This is actually what the
binding energy is for hydrogen
atom, and in fact, that makes
sense because in our extreme
case where we have total
shielding by the second
electron of the electron of
interest, it's essentially
seeing the same nuclear force
that an electron in a hydrogen
atom would see.
All right.
Let's consider now the second
extreme case, or extreme case
b, for our helium atom.
Again we have the charge of
the nucleus on plus 2, but
let's say this time the electron
now is going to be
very, very close
to the nucleus.
And let's say our second
electron now is really far
away, such that it's actually
not going to shield any of the
nuclear charge at all from
that first electron.
So what we end up saying is that
the z effective or the
effective charge that that first
electron feels is now
going to be plus 2.
Again, we can just plug this
into our equation, so if we
write in our numbers now saying
that z effective is
equal to 2, we find that we get
negative 2 squared r h,
all divided again by 1 squared
-- we're still talking about a
1 s orbital here.
And if we do that calculation,
what we find out is that the
binding energy, in this case
where we have no shielding, is
negative 8 .
7 2 times 10 to the negative
18 joules.
So, let's compare what we've
just seen as our two extremes.
So in extreme case a, we saw
that z effective was 1.
This is what we call
total shielding.
The electron completely canceled
out it's equivalent
of charge from the nucleus, such
that we only saw in a z
effective of 1.
In an extreme case b, we had
a z effective of 2, so
essentially what we had was
no shielding at all.
We said that that second
electron was so far out of the
picture, that it had absolutely
no affect on what
the charge was felt by
that first electron.
So, we can actually think about
now, we know the extreme
cases, but what is the reality,
and the reality is if
we think about the ionization
energy, and we measure it
experimentally, we find
that it's 3 .
9 4 times 10 to the negative
18 joules, and what you can
see is that falls right in the
middle between the two
ionization energies that
we would expect
for the extreme cases.
And this is absolutely
confirming that what is
happening is what we would
expect to happen, because we
would expect the case of reality
is that, in fact, some
shielding is going on, but it's
not going to be total
shielding, but at the same time
it's not going to be no
shielding at all.
And if we experimentally know
what the ionization energy is,
we actually have a way to find
out what the z effective will
be equal to.
And we can use this equation
here, this is just the
equation for the ionization
energy, which is the same
thing as saying the negative of
the binding energy that's
equal to z effective squared
r h over n squared.
So, what we can do instead of
talking about the ionization
energy, because that's one of
our known quantities, is we
can instead solve so that
we can find z effective.
So, if we just rearrange this
equation, what we find is that
z effective is equal to n
squared times the ionization
energy, all over the Rydberg
constant and the
square root of this.
So the square root of n
squared r e over r h.
So what's our value
for n here? one.
Yup, that's right.
And then what's our value
for ionization energy?
Yup.
So it's just that ionization
energy that we have
experimentally measured, 3 .
9 4 times 10 to the negative
18 joules.
We put all of this over the
Rydberg constant, which is 2 .
1 8 times 10 to the negative
18 joules, and we want to
raise this all to the 1/2.
So what we end up seeing is that
the z effective is equal
to positive 1 .
3 4.
So, this is what we find the
actual z effective is for an
electron in the helium atom.
Does this seem like a
reasonable number?
Yeah?
Who says yes, raise your hand
if this seems reasonable.
Does anyone think this
seems not reasonable?
OK.
How can we check, for example,
if it does or if it doesn't
seem reasonable.
Well, the reason, the way that
we can check it is just to see
if it's in between our
two extreme cases.
We know that it has to be more
than 1, because even if we had
total shielding, we would
at least feel is the
effective of 1.
We know that it has to be equal
to less than 2, because
even if we had absolutely no
shielding at all, the highest
z effective we could have is 2,
so it makes perfect sense
that we have a z effective that
falls somewhere in the
middle of those two.
So, let's look at another
example of thinking about
whether we get an answer
out that's reasonable.
So we should be able to
calculate a z effective for
any atom that we want to talk
about, as long as we know what
that ionization energy is.
And I'm not expecting you to
do that calculation here,
because it involves the
calculator, among maybe a
piece of paper as well.
But what you should be able to
do is take a look at a list of
answers for what we're saying
z effective might be, and
determining which ones are
possible versus which ones are
not possible.
So, why don't you take a look at
this and tell me which are
possible for a 2 s electron in
a lithium atom where z is
going to be equal to three?
Let's do 10 more seconds
on that.
OK, great.
So, the majority of
you got it right.
There are some people that are a
little bit confused still on
where this make sense, so, let's
just think about this a
little bit more.
So now we're saying that z
is equal to 3, so if, for
example, we had total shielding
by the other two
electrons, if they totally
canceled out one unit of
positive charge each in the
nucleus, what we would end up
with is we started with 3 and
then we would subtract a
charge of 2, so we would end up
with a plus 1 z effective
from the nucleus.
So our minimum that we're
going to see is that the
smallest we can have for
a z effective is going
to be equal to 1.
So any of the answers that
said a z effective of .
3 9 or .
8 7 are possible, they actually
aren't possible
because even if we saw a total
shielding, the minimum z
effective we would see is 1.
And then I think it looks like
most people understood that
four was not a possibility.
Of course, if we saw no
shielding at all what we would
end up with is a z
effective of 3.
So again, when we check these,
what we want to see is that
our z effective falls in between
the two extreme cases
that we could envision
for shielding.
And again, just go back and look
at this and think about
this, this should make sense if
you kind of look at those
two extreme examples, so even
if it doesn't make entire
sense in the 10 seconds you
have to answer a clicker
question right now, make sure
this weekend you can go over
it and be able to predict if you
saw a list of answers or
if you calculate your own answer
on the p-set, whether
or not it's right or it's wrong,
you should be able to
qualitatively confirm whether
you have a reasonable or a not
reasonable answer after you
do the calculation part.
All right.
So now that we have a general
idea of what we're talking
about with shielding, we can
now go back and think about
why it is that the orbitals
are ordered in the
order that they are.
We know that the orbitals for
multi-electron atoms depend
both on n and on l.
But we haven't yet addressed
why, for example, a 2 s
orbital is lower in energy than
the 2 p orbital, or why,
for example, a 3 s orbital is
lower in energy than a 3 p,
which in turn is lower
than a 3 d orbital.
So let's think about shielding
in trying to answer why, in
fact, it's those s orbitals that
are the lowest in energy.
And when we make these
comparisons, one thing I want
to point out is that we need to
keep the constant principle
quantum number constant, so
we're talking about a certain
state, so we could talk about
the n equals 2 state, or the n
equals 3 state.
And when we're talking about
orbitals in the same state,
what we find is that orbitals
that have lower values of l
can actually penetrate closer
to the nucleus.
This is an idea we introduced
on Wednesday when we were
looking at the radial
probability distributions of p
orbitals versus s orbitals
versus d orbitals.
But now it's going to make more
sense because in that
case we were just talking about
single electron atoms,
and now we're talking about
a case where we
actually can see shielding.
So what is actually going to
matter is how closely that
electron can penetrate to the
nucleus, and what I mean by
penetrate to the nucleus is is
there probability density a
decent amount that's very
close to the nucleus.
So, if we superimpose, for
example, the 2 s radial
probability distribution over
the 2 p, what we see is
there's this little bit of
probability density in the 2
s, but it is significant, and
that's closer to the nucleus
than it is for the 2 p.
And remember, this is in
complete opposition to what we
call the size of the orbitals,
because we know that the 2 p
is actually a smaller orbital.
For example, when we're
talking about radial
probability distributions, the
most probable radius is closer
into the nucleus than it
is for the s orbital.
But what's important is not
where that most probable
radius is when we're talking
about the z effective it
feels, what's more important
is how close the electron
actually can get the nucleus.
And for the s electron, since it
can get closer, what we're
going to see is that s electrons
are actually less
shielded than the corresponding
p electrons.
They're less shielded because
they're closer to the nucleus,
they feel a greater
z effective.
We can see the same thing when
we compare p electrons to d
electrons, or p and
d orbitals.
I've drawn the 3 p and the 3 d
orbital here, and again, what
you can see is that the p
electron are going to be able
to penetrate closer to the
nucleus because of the fact
that there's this bit of
probability density that's in
significantly closer to
the nucleus than it
is for the 3 d orbital.
And if we go ahead and
superimpose the 3 s on top of
the 3 p, you can see that the
3 s actually has some bit of
probability density that gets
even closer to the nucleus
than the 3 p did.
So that's where that trend comes
from where the s orbital
is lower than the d
orbital, which is
lower than the d orbital.
So now that we have this idea
of shielding and we can talk
about the differences in
the radial probability
distributions, we can consider
more completely why, for
example, if we're talking about
lithium, we write the
electron configuration as 1 s 2,
2 s 1, and we don't instead
jump from the 1 s 2 all the
way to a p orbital.
So the most basic answer that
doesn't explain why is just to
say well, the s orbital is lower
in energy than the p
orbital, but we now have a more
complete answer, so we
can actually describe
why that is.
And what we're actually
talking about
again is the z effective.
So that z effective felt by the
2 p is going to be less
than the z effective
felt by the 2 s.
And another way to say this, I
think it's easiest to look at
just the fact that there's some
probability density very
close the nucleus, but what we
can actually do is average the
z effective over this entire
radial probability
distribution, and when we find
that, we find that it does
turn out that the average of the
z effective over the 2 p
is going to be less than
that of the 2 s.
So we know that we can relate
to z effective to the actual
energy level of each of those
orbitals, and we can do that
using this equation here where
it's negative z effective
squared r h over n squared,
we're going to see
that again and again.
And it turns out that if we have
a, for example, for s, a
very large z effective or larger
z effective than for 2
p, and we plug in a large value
here in the numerator,
that means we're going
to end up with a very
large negative number.
So in other words a very low
energy is what we're going to
have when we talk about the
orbitals -- the energy of the
2 s orbital is going
to be less than the
energy of the 2 p orbital.
Another way to say that it's
going to be less, so you don't
get confused with that the fact
this is in the numerator
here, there is that negative
sign so it's less energy but
it's a bigger negative
number that gives us
that less energy there.
All right, so let's go back to
electrons configurations now
that we have an idea of why the
orbitals are listed in the
energy that they are listed
under, why, for example, the 2
s is lower than the 2 p.
So now we can go back and think
about filling in these
electron configurations
for any atom.
I think most and you are
familiar with the Aufbau or
the building up principle, you
probably have seen it quite a
bit in high school, and this is
the idea that we're filling
up our energy states, again,
which depend on both n and l,
one electron at a time starting
with that lowest
energy and then working
our way up into
higher and higher orbitals.
And when we follow the Aufbau
principle, we have to follow
two other rules.
One is the Pauli exclusion
principal, we discussed this
on Wednesday.
So this is just the idea that
the most electrons that you
can have in a single orbital
is two electrons.
That makes sense because we
know that every single
electron has to have its own
distinct set of four quantum
numbers, the only way that we
can do that is to have a
maximum of two spins in any
single orbital or two
electrons per orbital.
We also need to follow Hund's
rule, this is that a single
electron enters each
state before it
enters a second state.
And by state we just mean
orbital, so if we're looking
at the p orbitals here, that
means that a single electron
goes in x, and then it will go
in the z orbital before a
second one goes in
the x orbital.
This intuitively should make a
lot of sense, because we know
we're trying to minimize
electron repulsions to keep
things in as low an energy state
as possible, so it makes
sense that we would put one
electron in each orbital first
before we double up
in any orbital.
And the third fact that we need
to keep in mind is that
spins remain parallel prior to
adding a second electron in
any of the orbitals.
So by parallel we mean they're
either both spin up or they're
both spin down -- remember
that's our spin quantum
number, that fourth
quantum number.
And the reason for this comes
out of solving the
relativistic version of the
Schrodinger equation, so
unfortunately it's not as
intuitive as knowing that we
want to fill separate before
we double up a degenerate
orbital, but you just need to
keep this in mind and you need
to just memorize the fact that
you need to be parallel before
you double up in the orbital.
So, we'll see how this
works in a second.
So let's do this considering,
for example, what it would
look like if we were to write
out the electron configuration
for oxygen where z is going
to be equal to 8.
So what we're doing is filling
in those eight electrons
following the Aufbau principle,
so our first
electron is going to go in the 1
s, and then we have no other
options for other orbitals that
are at that same energy,
so we put the second electron
in the 1 s as well.
Then we go up to the 2 s, and we
have two electrons that we
can fill in the 2 s.
And now we get the p orbitals,
remember we want to fill up 1
orbital at a time before we
double up, so we'll put one in
the 2 p x, then one in the 2 p
z, and then one in the 2 p y.
At this point, we have no other
choice but to double up
before going to the next energy
level, so we'll put a
second one in the 2 p x.
And I arbitrarily chose to put
it in the 2 p x, we also could
have put it in the 2 p y or the
2 p z, it doesn't matter
where you double up, they're
all the same energy.
So if we think about what we
would do to actually write out
this configuration, we just
write the energy levels that
we see here or the orbital
approximations.
So if we're talking about
oxygen, we would say that it's
1 s 2, then we have 2 s 2, and
then we have 2 p, and our
total number of electrons in
the p orbitals are four.
So it's OK to not specify.
I want to point out, whether
you're in the p x, the p y, or
the p z, unless a question
specifically asks you to
specify the m sub l, which
occasionally will happen, but
if it doesn't happen you just
write it like this.
But if, in fact, you are asked
to specify the m sub l's, then
we would have to write it out
more completely, which would
be the 1 s 2, the 2 s 2, and
then we would say 2 p x 2, 2 p
z 1, and 2 p y 1.
So again, in general, just go
ahead and write it out like
this, but if we do ask you to
specify you should be able to
know that the p orbital
separates into these three --
the p sub-shell separates into
these three orbitals.
So let's do a clicker question
on assigning electron
configurations using the
Aufbau principle.
So why don't you go ahead and
identify the correct electron
configuration for carbon,
and I'll tell you that z
is equal to 6 here.
And in terms of doing this for
your homework, I actually want
to mention that in the back page
of your notes I attached
a periodic table that does
not have electron
configurations on them.
It's better to practice doing
electron configurations when
you cannot actually see the
electron configurations.
And this is the same periodic
table that you're going to get
in your exams, so it's good
to practice doing your
problem-sets with that periodic
table so you're not
relying on having the double
check right there of seeing
what the electron configuration
is.
So, let's do 10 seconds
on this problem here.
OK, great.
So this might be our best
clicker question yet.
Most people were able to
identify the correct electron
configuration here.
Some people, the next most
popular answer with 5%, which
is a nice low number, wanted to
put two in the 2 p x before
they moved on.
Remember we have to put one in
each degenerate orbital before
we double up on any orbital, so
just keep that rule in mind
that we would fill one in each
p orbital before we a to the
second one.
But it looks like you guys are
all experts here on doing
these electron configurations.
So, let's move on to some more
complicated electron
configurations.
So, for example, we can move
to the next periods in the
periodic table.
When we talk about a period,
we're just talking about that
principle quantum number, so
period 2 means that we're
talking about starting with
the 2 s orbitals, period 3
starts with, what we're
now filling into the
3 s orbitals here.
So if we're talking about the
third period, that starts with
sodium and it goes all
the way up to argon.
So if we write the electron
configuration for sodium,
which you can try later --
hopefully you would all get it
correctly -- you see that this
is the electron configuration
here, 1 s 2, 2 s 2, 2 p 6, and
now we're going into that
third shell, 3 s 1.
And I want to point out the
difference between core
electrons and valence
electrons here.
If we look at this
configuration, what we say is
all of the electrons in these
inner shells are what we call
core electrons.
The core electrons tend not to
be involved in much chemistry
in bonding or in reactions.
They're very deep and held very
tightly to the nucleus,
so we can often lump them
together, and instead of
writing them all out separately,
we can just write
the equivalent noble gas that
has that configuration.
So, for example, for sodium, we
can instead write neon and
then 3 s 1.
So the 3 s 1, or any of the
other electrons that are in
the outer-most shell, those are
what we call our valence
electrons, and those are where
all the excitement happens.
That's what we see are
involved in bonding.
It makes sense, right, because
they're the furthest away from
the nucleus, they're the ones
that are most willing to be
involved in some chemistry or in
some bonding, or those are
the orbitals that are most
likely to accept an electron
from another atom,
for example.
So the valence electrons, those
are the exciting ones.
We want to make sure we
have a full picture of
what's going on there.
So, no matter whether or not
you write out the full form
here, or the noble gas
configuration where you write
ne first or whatever the
corresponding noble gas is to
the core electrons, we always
write out the valence
electrons here.
So for sodium, again, we can
write n e and then 3 s 1.
We can go all the way down,
magnesium, aluminum, all the
way to this noble gas, argon,
which would be n e and then 3
s 2, 3 p 6.
Now we can think about the
fourth period, and the fourth
period is where we start to run
into some exceptions, so
this is where things get a teeny
bit more complicated,
but you just need to remember
the exceptions and then you
should be OK, no matter what
you're asked to write.
So for the fourth period, now
we're into the 4 s 1 for
potassium here.
And what we notice when we get
to the third element in and
the fourth period is that we go
4 s 2 and then we're back
to the 3 d's.
So if you look at the energy
diagram, what we see is that
the 4 s orbitals are actually
just a teeny bit lower in
energy -- they're just ever so
slightly lower in energy than
the 3 d orbitals.
You can see that as you fill up
your periodic table, it's
very clear.
But also we'll tell you a
pneumonic device to keep that
in mind, so you always remember
and get the orbital
energy straight.
But it just turns out that the
4 s is so low in energy that
it actually surpasses the 3 d,
because we know the 3 d is
going to be pretty high in terms
of the three shell, and
the 4 s is going to be the
lowest in terms of the 4
shell, and it turns out that
we need to fill up the 4 s
before we fill in the 3 d.
And we can do that just going
along, 3 d 1, 2 3, and the
problem comes when we get to
chromium here, which is
instead of what we would expect,
we might expect to see
4 s 2, 3 d 4.
What we see is that instead
it's 4 s 1, and 3 d 5.
So this is the first exception
that you need
to the Aufbau principle.
The reason this an exception is
because it turns out that
half filled d orbitals
are more stable than
we could even predict.
You wouldn't be expected to be
able to guess that this would
happen, because using any kind
of simple theory, we would, in
fact, predict that this would
not be the case, but what we
find experimentally is that it's
more stable to have half
filled d orbital than to have
a 4 s 2, and a 3 d 4.
So you're going to need to
remember, so this is an
exception, you have
to memorize.
Another exception in the fourth
period is in copper
here, we see that again, we have
4 s 1 instead of 4 s 2.
This is 4 s 1, 3 d 10, we might
expect 4 s 2, 3 d 9, but
again, this exception comes
out of experimental
observation, which is the fact
that full d orbitals also are
lower in energy then we could
theoretically predict using
simple calculations.
So again, you need to memorize
these two exceptions, and the
exception in general is that
filled d 10, or half-filled d
5 orbitals are lower in energy
than would be expected, so we
got this flip-flip where if we
can get to that half filled
orbital by only removing one s
electron, then we're going to
do it, and the same with
the filled d orbital.
And actually, when we get to
the fifth period of the
periodic table, that again takes
place, so when you get
to a half filled, or a filled
d orbital, again you want to
do it, so those exceptions would
be with molybdenum and
silver would be the
corresponding elements in the
fifth period where you're going
to see the same case
here where it's lower in energy
to have the half filled
or the filled d orbitals.
So here's the pneumonic I
mentioned for writing the
electron configuration and
getting those orbital energies
in the right order.
All you do is just write out
all the orbitals, the 1 s,
then the 2 s 2 p 3, 3 s 3 p d,
just write them in a straight
line like this, and then if you
draw diagonals down them,
what you'll get is the
correct order in
terms of orbital energies.
So if we go down the diagonal,
we start with 1 s, then we get
2 s, then 2 p and 3 s, then 3
p, and 4 s, and then that's
how we see here that 4 s is
actually lower in energy than
3 d, then 4 p, 5 s and so on.
So if you want to on an exam,
you can just write this down
quickly at the beginning and
refer to it as you're filling
up your electron configurations,
but also if
you look at the periodic table
it's very clear as you try to
fill it up that way that the
same order comes out of that.
So, whichever works best for
you can do in terms of
figuring out electron
configurations.
So the last thing I want to
mention today is how we can
think about electron
configurations for ions.
It turns out that it's going to
be a little bit different
when we're talking about
positive ions here.
We need to change our
rules just slightly.
So what we know is that these
3 d orbitals are higher in
energy than 4 s orbitals, so
I've written the energy of the
orbital here for potassium
and for calcium.
But what happens is that once a
d orbital is filled, I said
the two are very close in
energy, and once a d orbital
is filled, it actually drops to
become lower in energy than
the 4 s orbital.
So once we move past, we fill
the 4 s first, but once we
fill in the d orbital,
now that's going
to be lower in energy.
So that doesn't make a
difference for us when we're
talking about neutral atoms,
because we would fill up the 4
s first, because that's lower
in energy until we fill it,
and then we just keep going
with the d orbitals.
So, for example, if we needed
to figure out the electron
configuration for titanium, it
would just be argon then 4 s
2, and then we would
fill in the 3 d 2.
So, actually we don't have to
worry about this fact any time
we're dealing with neutrals.
The problem comes when instead
we're dealing with ions.
So what I want to point out is
what we said now is that the 3
d 2 is actually lower in energy,
so if we were to
rewrite this in terms of what
the actual energy order is, we
should instead write
it 3 d 2, 4 s 2.
So you might ask in terms of
when you're writing electron
configurations, which way
should you write it.
And we'll absolutely
accept both answers
for a neutral atom.
They're both correct.
In one case you decided to order
in terms of energy and
in one case you decided
to order in terms of
how it fills up.
I don't care how you do it on
exams or on problem sets, but
you do need to be aware that the
3 d once filled is lower
in energy than the 4 s, and
the reason you need to be
aware of that is if you're
asked for the electron
configuration now of
the titanium ion.
So, let's say we're asked
for the plus two ion.
So a plus two ion means that
we're removing two electrons
from the atom and the electrons
that we're going to
remove are always going to be
the highest energy electrons.
So it's good to write it like
this because this illustrates
the fact that in fact the 4 s
electrons are the ones that
are higher in energy.
So the correct answer for
titanium plus two is going to
be argon 3 d 2, whereas if we
did not rearrange our order
here we might have been tempted
to write as 4 s 2 so
keep that in mind when you're
doing the positive ions of
corresponding atoms. Alright,
so we'll pick up with
photoelectron spectroscopy
on Wednesday.
Have a great weekend.